二十四ページくらいありますね
このストーリーは で ストーリーは皆様早く読めるので
宿題として読んでみてください
で 最後のところだけ言います
コーサラ お釈迦様の時代
コーサラ国王がこのシャカ族からもお妃をもらったんですね
で コーサラ国王の考え方は
お釈迦様と親戚関係を作った方がいいやと
で お釈迦様もコーサラ国の人であると堂々と言っているんですね
お釈迦様はどこにもずっと泊まったことはないんですけど
長い間いたのはマガダ国ですけど
国王はもうお釈迦様はコーサラ国の人やと
一応人民権は与えたんですけどね
まあそれはまあ政治的な理由があると思いますけど
お釈迦様 シャカ族 シャカ国がコーサラ国の支配下にあったんですね
で だからこの小さな国でしたからね
お釈迦様の国は当時で
しかし すごい攻撃できない国でしたけど
一応大きい国とつなげた方がね
まあつなげてつなげて
そういうなんか政治をやっていたんです
合併して 合併というわけでもないんですけど
まあそんな感じですね
それで まあお釈迦様はコーサラ国の一人になるんです
そういうわけで で さらに仲良くしたいんだからお妃をもらったんですけど
まあでもシャカ族はこの関係ない人々にはもう血縁関係を作りたくないんですよ
いくらコーサラ王としたっても別な人間やと
でもこれ断れませんし
一人の女の人は娘やということであげたんですけど
父親はある王子なんですけど
その長老の大家で 当時で王でしたけどね
でも母親は家に仕事をしていた普通の召使いというかね
まあ人なんですね だからこの
でもそういう家で仕事をしている人
家来の人々と関係を持って子供が生まれても自分の子供として育てる
だから娘としてしっかりと育てたことは育てたんです
王様の娘だから 一応 じゃあこの子をあげましょうと
嘘言ったことになりませんし
私の娘でしょうし ということで
で これが後でバレちゃったんですね
誰にバレたかというと
コーサラ王様は全然そんなことは気にしませんでしたけども
娘 子供が生まれて 第一お妃にしちゃって
それで息子が生まれた
子供が生まれたんですね
子供がえらい傲慢なんですね
自分の血戚関係は父親よりも上やと
父親はシャカ族で 母親はもうシャカ族ですよと
インドであったカーストの中で一番トップのカーストなんです
バラモンよりもすごい上なんです
シャカ族は で バラモン人も家来で仕事をしていたみたいです
昔は そういうことだから
結構まあ傲慢ですね だから威張って自分の母親のところに行ったところで
何かちょっと出来事があってバレたんですよ
で そういうストーリー読めばあると思いますけど
まあどこまで事実かどうかは別に別としてね
まあそこまで言う必要はないんです
一応 王の皇太子が来るんだからね
国がお祭りして それはちゃんと歓迎はしたんですけど
それで何か何か出ていたところで
何か忘れ物があって ある知識人の人がもう大事なことで
あんたそれ帰って持ってきてくださいと
言うと その人だけもうまた皇太子が戻っちゃうと大変なことになるんだから
迷惑でしょ どちらでもね
で じゃああんたはこれまた持って帰ってこい
持ってきてくださいと頼んだ人が言うと
あの娘が座った椅子を洗っているんです
そちらに行ったら で それはちょっとおかしいということで
洗うと言ったっても いわゆる何て言いますか
この 何と言いますか 清める
って派手に洗っていたんです
とにかく それも全然もう気にしないで向こうに行く
でもあの洗っている連中からはもういろいろいろんなこと言ってるんだからね
耳に入ったんですね あの娘がね
座った椅子だから これで王様座れないでしょうと
いうことで 自分たちの気持ちを裏返って洗っているんです
これ聞いたら これがおかしいと
どうせそんな気楽にお嫁をくれるわけじゃないんだと
釈族はと それをあの人に言ったらものすごい怒ったんですね
それで決めた みんな殺すんだよと
で その名前はイルデブですけど
とにかくお釈迦様の国をもう攻めようと攻めようと何回何回も頑張ったんです
で お釈迦様はそれをやめさせたんですよ
一応アジャスよと違って
別にブッダに対して怒り
憎しみとか何もあったわけじゃないんだけど
そこら辺は何か行儀は良かったみたいだけど
お釈迦様あるいは軍隊が出ていくと真ん中座っていたんです
お釈迦様はそこら辺座っていて
軍隊は行かないんですね
それはイルデブ王様はお釈迦様礼をして
何でお釈迦様がこういうすごい楽でもないところでお座りになっているんでしょうかと
これはもう軍隊が進む道ですけどと
道のど真ん中みたいな
道と言っても道という道はなかったんですから
そこには木があって 木のそこに座っていたんですね
お釈迦様が家 この自分の国からね
吹いてくる風も楽しいと
それだけでした で これはまずいと
で 帰ったんです で これ回もやめさせたんですけど
もうやっぱり釈迦族のこれ運命やと
いうことで もう何回何回も王様に迷惑かけるわけにもいきませんしね
回目行って 一応みんな殺しちゃったんですね
一人残らず その釈迦族の人々はみんな殺しちゃったんです
それで平気で戦争に勝っているのは当たり前ですから
これは大国で あれは小国でね
だから ウパーサカ族はもう仏教に凝り固まって
もう戦争するとか全然考えたこともないし
予測もなかったしね もう攻撃するだろうというね
同じ国でしょうしね で
そのウィローディボーが帰ってきて
戦争で自分の国に戻るところで
川のそばで全部軍隊まとめて一晩泊まってキャンプを作ったんです
川のあれっていうのはかなり広い平らですからね
勝ちましたと で 何と言いますか
祝杯を挙げているんですよ
その遊んだり もう戦争も苦しいもんだからね
もう勝ってからやっぱりふざけていっぱい遊ぶでしょうしね
そんで夜寝たところで
朝みんな流されちゃったんです
川で 軍隊全部ウィローディボーもまとめて
結局 コーサラ王様には自分の大事な部族がなくなってしまったんです
そういうエピソードなんですね
だからまあ 夜寝ているとみんな流されるんですということで
でも偈の中でね 森 村という風に書いているんだからね
もしかするとそのエピソードは関係ないかもしれませんしね
まあ注釈書でつけてるエピソードですけどね
エピソードはエピソードで
偈は偈で独立させても構いませんし
お釈迦様はそういうちょっとした出来事は大げさにするということはありえないし
普遍的な真理を語っているんですね
やっぱり死の準備をしていないまま
死なないだろうと思っているまま
もうすぐ流されますよと
みんな だから それだけは絶対忘れてはいけないことですということで
その偈を唱えたそうです
[ページをめくる]